a 99 años todo un capítulo de la
historia contemporánea desde el reinado
de isabel segunda el duque de edimburgo
ha vivido capítulos trascendentales
desde una posición privilegiada
isabel segunda fue coronada en 1953 un
momento de posguerra cuando el mundo se
sumía en una guerra fría entre eeuu y la
unión soviética reino unido- siempre fue
la gran alianza estadounidense y también
en ese periodo los británicos entraron a
formar parte de la comunidad económica
europea eran 1973 y durante años los
lazos con europa fueron estrechos y la
corona participó en la inauguración del
eurostars que conectaría
ferroviariamente la isla británica con
francia pero no sólo el mundo ha mutado
desde ese momento también reinó unido-
de hecho el reinado de isabel 2ª y su
consorte felipe coincidió con la
desindustrialización la desregulación y
el auge del neoliberalismo con múltiples
huelgas de los sectores mineros un
período en el que destacó la
conservadora margaret thatcher bajo el
mandato de la cual se produjo la tierra
de las más
con argentina
también el duque de edimburgo presenció
el auge de la violencia en su territorio
con la banda terrorista' norirlandesa de
lira en un conflicto que dejó más de
3.500 muertos un nuevo orden mundial
tensión territorial de regulación e
incluso la mayor crisis económica desde
el crac del 29 de hecho en 2009
londres acogió el acuerdo del g20 para
superar la crisis económica y también
londres acogió en 2012 los juegos
olímpicos desde ese momento comenzaron
años de gran intensidad política para
los británicos primero con el referendo
de autodeterminación de escocia en 2014
el trasegar del break si desde el 2016
hasta su implementación en 2021 y una
pandemia mundial inacabada que ha
golpeado con fuerza el reino unido- una
episodio con el que cierra el ciclo de
la histórica vida del príncipe felipe